vor wem haben Sie mehr Angst haben sie
ja prinzipiell vor niemandem aber
Respekt vor Hubert eiwanger bei der
Bundestagswahl oder vor Sarah
Wagenknecht bei der Bundestagswahl also
ich glaube insgesamt wird Sara
Wagenknecht mehr bewegen deswegen man
hat es ja gesehen am selben Wahltag in
Bayern war ja auch Wahltag in Hessen und
es war am Höhepunkt dieser gesamten
medialen Diskussion und da waren es 3,5%
für die Freien Wähler auch respektabel
aber nicht ein annäheren Vergleich erwt
wie bei uns in Bayern auch in Bayern
übrigens war der Wert vor allem in der
Region Niederbayern sehr stark
fokussiert bei uns in Franken war es
deutlich weniger deswegen glaube ich
dass das da keine überragende Rolle
spielt bei aller bei allem Respekt vor
der Entscheidung mir macht eher die
Sorge was die destruktiven Kräfte gesamt
in Deutschland machen eine AFD die nach
wie vor auf Rekordniveau ist und eine
wagenknechtpartei die auch im Endeffekt
eher destruktive Lösungen bietet das ist
die größere Herausforderung für uns und
da muss man uns stellen und die
Demokraten brauchen mehr Kraft mehr Mumm
mehr
Entscheidungsfähigkeit